we now have a dynamic programming
algorithm
that's going to be able to reconstruct
ancestral states in binary trees
but this algorithm assumes that the
structure of the tree was given
for example here was an optimal solution
to the small parsimony problem
for our toy multiple alignment of four
species if we're dealing with unrooted
trees
but it assumes that chimp and human are
neighbors
and that seal and whale are neighbors
it seems unlikely but there's nothing
preventing chimp and seal from being
neighbors instead
we need to find the smallest parsimony
score for this unrooted tree as well
which is 11. we also need to find the
smallest parsimony score for the tree
in which chimp and whale are neighbors
where that score is also 11.
now i'll have you note that when
applying our algorithm for small
parsimony
we're going to allow an internal edge to
have weight zero
as shown here because if we were to
compress this edge then we would no
longer have a binary tree
so this brings us to the large parsimony
problem
in which we must find an assignment of
ancestral states
to internal nodes over all possible
unrooted binary tree structures
as you might guess this problem is
np-complete
so let's design a greedy heuristic for
this problem
first i want you to think about removing
an internal edge of an unrooted binary
tree
i.e an edge that connects two internal
nodes
along with the nodes that it connects so
for example
if we delete the edge connecting a and b
here along with the nodes
a and b themselves then we can see that
we have disconnected this
unrooted binary tree into four disjoint
subtrees
that i'll denote w x y and z
there are three ways to then rearrange
these four sub trees around that
internal edge that connected a
and b so the operation in which we move
from
one of these trees to the other is
called a nearest neighbor interchange
for this internal edge connecting a and
b
to test your knowledge of this operation
you might like to implement a program
that
returns the two nearest neighbors of a
given unrooted binary tree
with respect to a given internal edge
this program will then be used for the
nearest neighbor interchange heuristic
for the large parsimony problem which
begins with an arbitrary unrooted binary
tree
then performs all possible nearest
neighbor interchanges
over every possible internal edge of the
tree
then solving the small parsimony problem
for each such unrooted tree
now if we find a tree whose minimum
parsimony score improves over the
current tree that we have
then we set the current tree equal to
this tree and we iterate
otherwise we can't improve on the
current tree via a nearest neighbor
interchange
and we simply return the current tree
try implementing this greedy heuristic
yourself before we move on
to the final section of this chapter